so look one of the initiatives we are
most proud of at Warner Brothers
Discovery Sports is the Oscar Pope Lift
Every Voice initiative it honors one of
our late colleagues Oscar Pope and his
passion was elevating the next wave of
sports media journalists and so this
year we honored generica Owens who's a
rising senior at Clark Atlanta
University this is going to be her first
big shot on TV and you're going to be
seeing a bunch of her I'm sure because
she is that good and we're so happy that
you're our teammate today generica what
you got going on down there thank you
Ernie it's a pleasure to be here
alongside four-time NBA champ Draymond
Green in two-time Super Bowl champ Von
Miller how are you guys doing today
I'm doing pretty good man we got a great
day on the golf course
kicking it with other Champions
um just hanging out it's gonna be a fun
day now I have to start it off with this
we have NBA versus NFL which league has
the better player
well I think we 100 have the better
player I think everyone in the world
knows that Steph Curry is like and take
this with a grain of salt with no
disrespect to professional golfers
because I understand how hard it is to
be a pro in anything but Steph Curry is
like
professional lever golfer so there's no
way these NFL guys can compete and I'm
going to collect my money and I'm happy
about it you heard it from Dre what do
you have to say bun
I go against these guys Travis Kelsey
Patrick Mahomes all the time
Patrick Mahomes is a champion
on and off the football field I want to
see Patrick Mahomes go crazy we know we
got Steph Curry
we know we got Clay Thompson two of the
best Duos in sports let's just see what
happens
now Draymond you know Clay and Stefan
competition better than anyone else what
are your expectations from them on the
course today my expectations are
that clay will rise to the level I know
I've been needling clay this entire time
but my expectation is that he's going to
rise to the level and play even better
than Steph today like that's who Clay is
when there's a moment he's rising up to
the occasion and he's taking on that
moment and I have zero doubt that he's
going to do that today thank you thank
you
back to you